this is Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist and for
this edition of Startalk it will be
cosmic queries
I think it's a grab-bag edition but I
got a check with my co-host Chuck nice
Chuck yes what's up Neil and you are
stressed so there are the first query
has been answered first query is what
are the queries about that so what
happens is we solicit normally we
solicit topics but other is sort of
dribble in and they they sort of collect
we're housekeeping really but getting
tending to the questions that are
completely random coming from every
direction of every compass direction of
the universe what just good to because
people get very upset when their
questions go and when their questions go
unanswered but they don't realize that
when we're soliciting new questions it's
because it's a different topic like you
said it's a different thing yeah it's
not like we can just continue so yeah
you're right this is a great way to do
some housekeeping them make some people
happy in so let's do this let's do this
all right before we begin so what does a
comedian do in the shutdown Korona verse
do the the clubs are closed right so
they just tell jokes to your wife and
your kids they don't want to hear any of
my deadly what my kids don't even want
I'll never the worst day was when I
walked in and my wife was like oh good
you're home let's watch and there was
something I had done some TV shows that
she had taped and she didn't watch it
just so that she could watch it with me
it was like the first episode of
something I was on and both my children
I have three but two of them were
sitting and they both like without Q way
when do we have two Danny's on TV
he's right here yeah yeah no I mean I'm
actually just doing the only thing
that's available which is remote
voice work so okay yes you got a good
voice for it yeah so I um I can't say
which but I've booked several
commercials I can't say which ones yet
because you're not allowed to say what
commercial you're on until it actually
airs and they won't be this is just a
start or audience we won't tell him yeah
that's okay just which way between you
and me no worried about nation da you
scientist so yeah so just look for my
voice on a couple things you know that
if you I have commercials written to the
point where they have NDA's
know what the hell you're just
advertised yes yeah it's it's really
strange how secretive and like how just
overbearing you might say but then that
when I think about it
you're talking about if you look at the
industry as a whole billions bill
dollars so basically it's because they
don't want whatever the client is
doesn't want their competitor to know
what it is that they're doing
you know that's understand yes alright
let's just write into this of course
gave to me patreon is first always with
patreon so oh boy we calling this
potpourri or galactic gumbo I like gumbo
you know with the Dumbo let him know you
know see know down in do know the left
don't mean we missile Dumbo all right
yeah local at the gumbo I love it
so let's start with a patreon patron
this is Abdul Aziz bin or a job and he
says hey quick question
what form or thing can sustain itself
and not be destroyed by a black hole or
what thing can sustain itself the most
and to which degree would it be able to
hold itself together when they're
entering a black hole so is there
anything that can withstand the oh your
term I'm about to use is there anything
that isn't spaghettified when it goes
into a black hole
No ooh next question oh so what happens
it's a very simple calculation normally
when we think of materials so you know
we have eggs that will break or steel
that strong or rubber that's flexible so
we have these sort of macroscopic
descriptors for these things in our
lives when you analyze it at a molecular
level because that's all the black hole
is going to care about and then the
atomic level as you fall towards the
black hole what gets you is that what I
call the tidal forces these are the
forces that will stretch you head to toe
as you fall it are you sure you want to
go the old rhyme I pen 30 years ago but
anything so so what's happening is the
party that's closer to the black hole
singularity feels a stronger gravity
than the part of you that's farther so
in a feet-first dye if your feet will
start falling towards the black hole
that towards the singularity faster than
your head will that's not a good
situation to be in you initially feels
like a stretch you know who doesn't like
a good stretch but then you realize that
it is unrelenting and growing and it
reaches a point where the tidal forces
exceed the molecular bonds that hold
your flesh together then you snap in two
pieces your upper half and your lower
half of your body and then but you might
say well how about a brick of steel yeah
steel is held together more strongly
than your body is but there's still a
breaking point for the atoms of steel
and for the molecules that make up the
steel sector the carbon the iron and all
that comprise the alloy that is the
steel they're connected by some force
and you can calculate what that force is
and there's a distance from the center
of the black hole where the tidal forces
will be so great it'll rip apart the
molecules and the atoms of your solid
block of steel yes that will happen
closer in then what would rip you apart
yes but it'll still just still going to
happen it's still gonna have not only
that it'll rip the atoms themselves
apart and then nuclei
I'm saying that's insane oh man that's
serious that's that's that's evil yeah
evil the evil forces so therefore this
is where gravity wins over atoms nice so
now let me just take up duels question
and for my own edification go a little
further so when you're looking at the
creation of a supermassive black hole
when you get down to the place where
it's the star that's dying is producing
iron and now there's nothing that can
happen after that so it's like okay I'm
gonna collapse in on myself right so now
okay so now you're the iron is already
there up what happens as these things or
whatever it is whatever matter it maybe
falls towards this singularity when it
gets there is it is it is it infinitely
compressed does it have like a core does
it what is happening at that point since
you have these streams of particles that
are now just they're not even particle
they are just four six you say where do
they land that's what I'm trying to
figure out so so the only way to find
out truck is if we send to you if you
report back okay it's the fourth back so
here's here's the problem Einstein's
general theory of relativity which gives
us the large-scale structure of the
universe and a Big Bang and and black
holes and the like shows us that at the
center of the black hole the
gravitational force exceeds everything
molecular and atomic and in fact the
compresses matter to a point of
infinitely small size which means it has
infinite density right now that's just
crazy that is so it may be I mean
actually crazy evil when I'm trying to
think of this but it can't yet maybe
that doesn't happen Oh what I'm telling
you is Einstein's general theory of
relativity predicts that so that could
be the edge of where Einstein relativity
applies
accurately to the universe maybe before
it hits the singularity some other law
of physics needs to be invoked to extend
our understanding of the universe beyond
where Einstein then leaves us off okay
I'm a Newton left us off
Newton's forces operated under
relatively low gravity and low speeds
and it failed at high gravity in high
speeds we needed Einstein to go into the
into the dark closet of the unknown but
now we know in advance that general
relativity has these limits and so enter
string theorists they come in and talk
about the singularity they've got a
whole mathematical formalism to think
about the singularity and so it so
either it really is infinitely small and
if it we dance or there's another branch
of physics that still needs work string
theory still needs work to give us an
understanding of that particular regime
in the cosmos so yeah I can't so the
answer the the answer that question is I
don't have an answer right well clearly
no one does what we do know what we do
know you didn't ask this but I will tell
you what we do know is that the we used
to think or hope that if you went into a
black hole it's a portal to another
place perhaps perhaps another dimension
another universe itself the problem is
it turns out the information that
entered the black hole will ultimately
come back out of that same black hole
through Hawking radiation the black hole
basically evaporate given enough time
it'll lose its mass through particles
and the inventory of those particles
that came out equals the inventory of
particles that went in which tells us
that you can't take stuff put it through
a black hole and have it show up
somewhere else
wow that may still remain sense it still
remains in this universe it's a
remarkable discovery modern quantum
physics and black holes that's
incredible
yes that isn't correct yeah so the
evaporation of black hole through
Hawking radiation kinda lets you know
that it's not going anywhere
exact
chuckling it's actually coming back out
coming back coming back out what kind of
bucket I said just so people in case you
didn't know what Hawking radiation is
you remember the equals mc-squared you'd
learn this in elementary school
there's the equivalence of energy and
mass e equals M energy and mass and C
squared is a as a constant there's a
speed of light but there's actually not
important about what I'm about to
describe so you can convert energy into
mass and mass into energy they're
interchangeable so it turns out in the
vicinity of a black hole the energy
density of the gravitational field is so
high that the energy will spontaneously
create particle pairs and it creates a
matter and antimatter particle 1
particle falls back into the black hole
the other escapes and that's the
narration and you take the inventory of
those particles and it is exactly what
fell in and guess we get a find in the
first place that's amazing yeah oh my
god don't wait a minute so it just
dawned on me then so what you just
described though the information you
called it information that means that
there's a change of information then so
wait just to be clear what's for me
mind-blowing is matter enters the black
hole right that's what I'm saying yeah
and then the black hole has gravity
because of that matter and the
gravitational field when it generates
new particles makes remembers remembers
the matter inventory of what fell into
the black hole in the first place oh my
god yes that's amazing
there is some communication in the
system where the entire system remembers
what matter it had eaten it has to
because otherwise it wouldn't be able to
create the same portfolio right to to to
put it off to send it out and desperate
so this for me that was the most amazing
fact about that discovery oh my god and
and it's it's upsetting to science
fiction folks because you want to go
into black hole and come out somewhere
else so now we need some other way to go
to leave the universe
okay mm-hmm amen great question uh other
tool all right much all right let's see
guys okay here we go let's let's do is
that only one question we're almost out
of time for this first row all right
it's just good start go all right here
we go this is a giannis theosis okay
that said your name wrong man sorry
gianna still you know what I'm talking
about from Facebook he says what will be
more groundbreaking as a discovery and
why understanding dark matter or
discovering life outside of our solar
system or even for it you know okay so
the Dark Matter question would be
amazing it's the longest unsolved
problem longest standing unsolved
problem in astrophysics it's good we're
going on 90 years not knowing what dark
matter is today okay so yeah yeah so if
we learn what it is that would be a
great day in astrophysics however if
it's simply another kind of particle
that doesn't interact with our own and
it's out there with that we're
hypothesizing anyway that's not as
interesting as if dark matter were the
gravitational effect of a parallel
universe influence it whatever it is
I'd want it to have far reaching
implications for me to get excited about
it okay is it if we know dark matter to
then we know dark energy and is there
another thing do we now can we unpack
black holes because we know is there
some other thing that it comes with is
it some package deal with other unsolved
problems that get solved with it if not
I'm going with the discovery of life
elsewhere on and another on an exoplanet
because that for two reasons if it's
made of DNA either we're shared DNA and
life got around in the early formations
of solar systems or DNA is an inevitable
consequence
of complex organic chemistry right so
that wherever you find life it would
then be DNA based now think about it is
that so much of a stretch if you go to
Mars you find rocks that are familiar
right if you go if you go to Europa you
find ice that you have seen before so
geology and chemistry seem to repeat you
see volcanoes geela on Io one of
Jupiter's moons so why would biology
have to be sort of unique to one place
and not be a highly repeatable
phenomenon that's a fair question to ask
but what I can tell you that so it would
be interesting if it was based on DNA
for both of those reasons it would be
even more interesting if it had nothing
to do with DNA yet it still was life
self-replicating thriving that that
would be like oh we got to open up our
definition and understand and our
understanding of what life is and then
then the biologists who you know they
celebrate the diversity of life but
behind closed doors but they got to be
honest with themselves you know what
they say you know what that honesty is
oh look at the diversity of my plants
and animals and fungi in behind closed
doors it's all it's it's pretty much the
same as its routine it's it's it's it's
wayna it's not in special baby all life
has one common all right so what you
want is another genesis and then you can
compare and contrast well life requires
this but doesn't require that well you
know we used to think life required a 72
degree tide pool you know just no no you
have extremophiles doing the backstroke
in acid under radiation conditions so
every every new thing we learn about
life on Earth tells us how Hardy life is
and how resilient it is to stress to a
system even if an organism dies life in
general seems to thrive and so if we
find life thriving under conditions on
dreamt of with a chemistry unimaginative
signing up another
particle to add to the particles ooh
that we then credit for being dark
matter the particles though I think I'm
gonna take my kids there Chuck got to
take a quick break when we come back
more cosmic queries galactic no you say
no home glad Nick gumbo okay you know me
mouse and I'll guarantee when we return
your back Startalk cosmic queries
grab-bag edition but Chuck calls it
something else yeah
gumballs got a lot of different
ingredients in that's why we're saying
yeah Gumbo's got what you got man you
got everything that crap you got so hold
on you got cross and do we salty do it
and you're also right that's right yeah
I think I told you this I don't know if
we talked about it on the air or
privately but Yvonne Gagne gosh-darn man
gotta get you some of Yvonne Gagne gumbo
that she's a friend of the family from
New Orleans who used to make gumbo that
would so so where is it so I'm waiting
for talk about it you do something you
have never mentioned it on or off the
air because I haven't had it yet here we
go let's go to rearm somebody who says
are we done with the patreon questions
no this is also sorry from patriarchy
still Pedro they have people that pay
their way to the top of the list they do
the American Way as we call it your
Senate
like okay here we go
Rhian wants to know this he's very
poetic so I'm just gonna read all this
everything here because he's very poor
they killed he says the sky calls to us
if we do not destroy ourselves
will we one day venture to the stars it
was Carl Sagan's lifetime mission to
encourage humanity to explore the
universe and you Neil are calling for
the same goal and carrying the message
to a new generation given the recent
promising spaceflight developments of
SpaceX do you think that during our
lifetime we will finally see humans
colonizing other planets or at least
finding a glimpse of intelligent life on
other world
that's beautiful yeah yeah this is a guy
this is a guy who spends a lot of time
reading your stuff clearly okay so the
answer's no I'm just being mean oh that
was a hot knife and twisted Wow he's
okay so eloquently asked this very like
just super optimistic question and are
you serious do you really think no yeah
yeah you said our lifetime no but can I
tell you why I need to pull that out of
my ass I have reasons for this thinking
this okay it's think about it
what other planet in our own solar
system comes closest to anyone possibly
living on it which which plan it's none
what Mars used to be March March March
okay now because Mars like has polar
icecaps it's has seasons it's it's near
us in the habitable zone it once had
liquid running water doesn't today may
be underwater underground in a
permafrost frozen so okay Mars you ain't
going to Venus is 900 degrees Fahrenheit
500 degrees Celsius yeah it's hotter
than a pizza oven you ain't go into
Venus
you're not going to mercury it's almost
as hot okay some Mars do you realize
that Antarctica is wetter and ball near
than every location on Mars yeah I don't
see people lining up to buy condos in
Antarctica that's colonized that's cuz
Superman's a lousy neighbor he's an
excuse me he's in the North Pole now oh
is he okay yeah yeah I think I'm pretty
sure it's the North Pole but they're
they showed land but there's no land in
the North Pole so they got that wrong
that's okay but Santa is on an ice floe
that's right but whatever whatever's
left of it okay Santa's in a bathing
suit right now
sipping sipping pina coladas with a
polar bear wearing sunglasses you know
what if we're laughing but it's so sad
but go ahead be excused for Santa to get
get buffs right if he's other than a
bathing suit on an ice floe sipping a
drink would give Santa with ABS that'd
be interesting but so we don't see that
happening so the urge to live on Mars
would be novel initially I think but to
say I want to live here forever I don't
see that happening as an urge you'll
want to get back to your vacation there
briefly but you want to get back to
earth
and so I'm suspecting so for me what
you'd have to do is terraform the
planets first then their earth-like and
they can go there and pitch tent and
you're you get off the the spaceship and
you don't suffocate step when Columbus
arrived in the New World
as the as one of the first Europeans I
guess after the Vikings when he stepped
off his ship he could breathe the air he
met other people here who greeted him he
could eat the fruit on the vines he
could repair his ship why because the
trees in the new world were made of wood
just like the trees in Europe so when
people speak of the next generation of
space exploration analogizing to that
era of explorers you're missing the
point about dying when you step off the
ship so it is supremely hostile to human
physiology that's all I'm saying
and and plus if we do go to another
planet and find civilizations I'd like
to think we've learned something about
how to interact with people who are
there to greet you so lessons from the
Columbus chapter of colonization is if
you do find all the life-forms
how what's the playbook for how we're
going to interact with those life-forms
be they what we designate as intelligent
or not by the way NASA hasn't
higher branch of itself called planetary
protection which is if you're going to
visit a place that might have life
then set a probe there you have to
sterilize the probe completely so that
if you sneezed on it before it was
launched you don't get Rhino virus on on
the on the planet that you're gonna be
expects or in for life itself and for
any samples that get returned to Earth
they have to be quarantined to make sure
that nothing then contaminates earth
cool so it's my longer answer but the
answer is still no Wow I'm and yeah look
it's the visit yeah but not to call I
don't see colonization yeah it makes any
time soon it makes sense sorry I'm sorry
buddy yeah okay sorry buddy
there we go this is Brett Marshall from
Facebook and I just have to read this
because I you know it's I don't know why
it goes hey I'm still here and I'm still
too stupid to come up with a good
question but okay but I listen to every
show hey still here still too stupid to
come up with a good question listen to
every show please remember to might be
but he's on Facebook
he's so appreciate the sentiment but by
the way it's I don't judge whether
questions good or not in the end is my
answer good that you should be judging
my answer not whether you think your
question is good right don't ask
anything that any ask anything you feel
that's what matters here okay all right
here we go this is dawuan only the one
only from instagram hello dr. Tyson how
far do you think our advancements in
science would be if the United States
budget used for the military was
actually used towards science and
technology okay so the budget I haven't
looked at the very latest budget but
last time I looked the budget for the
National Science Foundation was about 30
billion dollars
gnats NASA's budgets about 20 billion so
you put them together you get about
fifty billion there are other ways we
spend money on science for example the
National Institutes of Health does
medical research this sort of thing so
if you add up all the portfolio's in all
disciplines of science research in
America you get up maybe 70 billion
maybe a hundred billion dollars okay
yeah that's a lot of money the military
spends 600 billion every year Oh on the
military no a lot of that is standing
armies literally a matter to me that
yeah it's like you know pay-or-play it's
like what if oh you want to fight a war
that's on top right it's that right you
know I don't know you want to find a war
we need more money for that okay so so
it's not always true that throwing money
at something at that high rate leads to
a discovery sometimes you have to move
through a place where new ideas
percolate germinate and maybe those new
ideas come from the from the wrong
result it could be a long result says
wait a minute no we would do minute
wrong the whole time it's really this
and you couldn't have had that thought
unless you landed in a place where you
had done it wrong in the first place
some of this takes time so I I would say
the way to think about this is that peer
review of research grants and so I write
a grant I said I want to do this
research and I can take me this long
it'll take me this much money I want to
hire this many people I want to do it in
this location and they approve
okay so here's what happens depending on
how much money there isn't how many
people are playing you get to grant 10%
of applications uh-huh sometimes 50 well
how about the other 85% well you can say
well these are just not worth funding
but these others were on the border and
they should be funded but we can't fund
everything you want money for those okay
that would I think double the what we're
currently spending so I would say if you
want as healthy a science budget as you
have given the number of scientist in
the country
if you doubled all the science budgets
that would get is pretty far pretty
quickly now how advanced would we be
again it's a matter of time okay if
civilization didn't spend so much time
in the Dark Ages or rejecting what
science could have been if scientists
weren't sorcerers or people who had some
knowledge of the natural world if we'd
work crediting the oceans to Zeus sort
of the wrath of God or to other
supernatural forces and we sit in a way
to it maybe they're natural forces had
that begun earlier it's possible we
might have been on the moon in the
nineteenth century rather than in the
20th century but again it takes
developments right you have to figure
out oh we need this new material waiting
that we have to dig for it well where we
gonna dig is the geology up to match
through with that and we have to
understand the human physiology it's
medicine at that place so it's very
complicated in a in a good way it's
complicated I mean you want you want a
lot of different things happening but
you also need bridges and tunnels
connecting these discoveries so that the
next innovation can exploit what had
come before in any discipline that it
needs to make that happen so I would say
to punch science along at the rate it
should you'd have to double all budgets
and otherwise yeah we've probably lost a
few centuries in the history of
civilization because of people standing
in denial the role of natural forces
relative to supernatural yeah
and we're headed back there so yeah the
way to go way to go world way to go
[Laughter]
what's that I tweeted recently I said
every disaster movie begins but people
ignoring the warnings were science
that's right okay this is em Jonesy 19
from Instagram he says can you please
explain the horizon problem it would
seem that no matter where you are you
are in the center of the universe which
means all locations are the center of
the universe that really bets another
question is there a center
the universe and how many licks does it
take to get to the center of that
universe if you're over 60 you'll
remember that TV commercial for the
Tootsie Pop now they brought that back
how many licks does it take to get to
the center of a Tootsie Pop or something
like that yeah yeah it depends on how
slobbery you are yeah I knew that was a
kid when I first I was nine I said it
depends on how wet your tongue is you
can what are you even doing here you
know so I Mudd was it's because you'll
bite it before you look all the way that
was the UH that's didn't get us the
catch yeah yeah because you get the guy
so good I can't wait to lick all the way
down right what is the horizon problem
yeah well there are other brothers the
buddies sighting is not entirely the
horizon problem so but let me just
explain horizons right when you're a
ship at sea and if you just look around
the distance from you to the last bit of
water that you can detect is the same in
every direction and that distance is
farther the higher up you are in the
ship so the quote crow's nest the
highest point auto ship is where the
lookout person stood to see to look for
icebergs to look for land they would be
the first to see this because they have
the farthest view over the curvature of
the earth land ho right yeah exactly
it's that person who's cited it not
someone looking over the railing so so
so it's clear and understandable that if
you're at sea the horizon is the same
distance to you in each direction okay
now another ship also in the middle of
the ocean has the same they see their
owner everybody is the middle of their
own horizon ocean and what we don't know
in our own universe is whether is there
points you can stand where your horizon
doesn't go the same distance out does it
end and in principle yes in principle
but what I can tell you is that every
direction
look when we look 14 billion light-years
distant we see the origin of the
universe just now reaching us so that
means everybody at that distance okay at
that time distance away from us is
experiencing the beginning of the
universe if in this direction they were
not and I saw a regular galaxy there and
in this direction I see them being born
whoa that would mean I'm a land ho okay
would mean this direction is different
from this direction mmm and if you're
out at sea if there's land that way but
see in every other direction water in
every other direction something
different just happened and so that
becomes a more intriguing part of the
universe we all be focused that way if
that were in fact the case now the
horizon problem as stated just the
horizon from means something different
from what he asked and it has to do with
if this horizon is very different from
that horizon or there's several
manifestations of this but one of them
is how can that part of the universe be
at exactly the same temperature as this
part of the universe how would it know
to be the same temperature unless the
whole universe was somehow connected to
itself in a very small place all right
and it had to be really connected
because the difference in temperature in
every direction is like a hundredth of a
degree Kelvin Wow you you don't have
that consistency of temperature from one
side of your room to the other much less
one side of the universe to the other
and so this is part of what we think of
as the horizon problem and that's where
we got to inflationary cosmology so
these are the details that's in that
what I call it in the in the weeds of
the Big Bang when they saw the Big Bang
is having problems know there's just
challenges within the weeds but the
broader picture that we began as an
explosion 14 billion years ago that's
intact it's like what's going on in the
weeds that we have to try to understand
enter say wow all right well cool cool
we've got it in there we've got one more
segment left all right cosmic queries
and Pokiri
cosmic queries grab-bag cosmic queries
they'll add big Dumbo no when we return
we're back Startalk cosmic queries grab
back position for us Chuck says lat be
Dumbo not Hall that [ __ ]
I think we have more questions ask them
there are ingredients in gumbo no we do
that and all not a lot of question they
get go get doing work boom boom get to
the question guarantee mr. um this is P
an wonders who wants to know this with
earth gathering mass from space material
all the time when will the mass increase
to have an effect on Earth's orbit and
what would that effect be yeah that's a
great question so earth plows through in
our orbit earth plows through several
hundred tons of meteor dust a day
hundreds of tons okay so write down that
number several hundred tons in a day
times 365 days times four billion years
and figure out how much mass that is and
then compare that to the actual mass of
the earth that's like a net flying full
speed ahead into an elephant and the
elephant said I quit the shovel yeah
that's not gonna happen it is it is it
is uninterestingly small relative to the
total mass of the earth so no not not to
worry so nothing to worry about there
negligible last days just sleep sleep
sleep sleep well tonight yes Ian wanders
oh by the way there's something else
happening the Sun is slowly losing mass
through solar wind you've heard of our
solar wind these are particles have you
wish your concern about the sun's mass
well the Sun is actually get a lighter
and as it gets lighter the speed with
which we are in our orbit is too fast to
maintain that orbit and it goes to a
higher orbit okay so in fact the fact
that the Sun is losing mass is making
Earth's spot slowly spiral away from
them and the Sun will lose mass at an
ever-faster rate as the billions of
years unfold
and we'll end up there all the planets
will end up warbling farther and farther
away last one of the fates fates of the
solar system the solar system is a cruel
cruel mistress it's it's yes yeah it's
crazy crazy all right here we go
bugger dude from Instagram
bugger dude says this how the
astronomers find out that the edge of
the observable universe is 43 billion
light-years away okay so let's let's
resolve this so most of us we
astrophysicists when we think of the
edge of the universe we say it's 14
billion light years away that's not
really true okay
the part of the universe we can see the
light that was sent by that has been
traveling for 14 billion years but that
thing that emitted the light that's not
14 billion light years away right now it
has been part of the expanding universe
and is now 40 low 40 43 45 billion light
years away in that direction and 45
billion light years away in that
direction so want to speak of the
diameter of the universe you're talking
90 billion light years you just don't
observe that and so so much of my field
tries to anchor itself in what you can
see rather than what you calculate to be
true so yes we can calculate how far
away that galaxy is that we're watching
right now being born 14 billion years
ago in the Big Bang where is it today
it's a full-grown galaxy it's a it's
fully grateful red-blooded gal and there
it is or green-blooded if it's got
copper for its DEMA globin and there it
is 45 billion light-years away and you
don't see it there so that's how that
was so if you have to calculate based on
the known expansion rate of the universe
where that is today right so basically
the cosmos is an annoying grandmother
that pulled out an album of baby
pictures
[Laughter]
yeah I guess a little bit and who pulls
out albums of anything yeah Chuck how
old are you oh I still know I still keep
I print out my photos a night and I put
the pants to my question how old were
you well it's the same as scrapbooking
as far as I'm concerned it's like you
know because you know why ladies and
gentlemen Chuck is 75 years old just a
black black don't crack so he looks good
you know what and your rheumatism is
acting it's gonna rain well it's gonna
rain tomorrow no okay so here we go this
is a Scott and his last name yeah that's
the car okay Patrick are all right like
I picture that what you have to think
about that Chuck you're not just you
have to read it and think about it and
then say it yeah because I mean you know
okay okay I mean ah Scott I didn't have
to think about you know okay that looks
pretty cool but other than that oh it's
a crock I bet you okay anyway hello dr.
Tyson and hey please pronounce my name I
shot okay yeah I shot his you know where
I shot thank you my friend he gave me
there you go he says my question is that
about 400 years ago Sir Isaac Newton hey
Neal I know that's your man discovered
the laws of motion and gravity he also
discovered calculus and had already
discovered the laws of optics
how was he so focused and deeply
indulged in his work during the plague
which was a pandemic during that time
how was he able to manage his mental
health and how can we manage our own
mental health and have a spark of our
own creativity and imagination
during
time of peak anxiety and a shot is
coming to us from India love who thank
you our shot so first I don't claim any
mental health expertise but I do know a
little bit about Isaac Newton and I know
a little bit about others who have made
singular contributions to our
understandings of the natural world and
one of the things they all had in common
was that they had episodes in their life
either forced upon thrust upon them by
Isaac Newton escaping the Black Plague
in London and in Cambridge he was a
professor at Cambridge or at least in
school at Cambridge or whether or or if
you have an injury that sort of lays you
up for a period of time all these people
have long periods of time where they
were in solitude solitude and so the
brain just explored on its own today
other than families that have many young
kids running up and down so there is no
solitude and everyone is is quarantined
together there are others who just can't
go to work and you live alone you can't
go to the bar or the club so what are
you doing are you sitting alone on the
couch thinking or are you binging on the
latest Netflix series so we live in a
time where many people's creative juices
that might have otherwise flowed are
arrested because they have distractions
in their life evening television
on-demand television streaming services
so I lament
I wonder what discoveries remain
unrevealed sit by brilliant people today
simply because of the distractions we
have built into our own lives and the
distractions are fun they're not chores
there we enjoy them all right but and
sitting alone by yourself staring to the
ceiling no one would call that enjoyment
but that's exactly the conditions under
which Isaac Newton
plated the cosmos and dark contemplated
the cosmos his long walks alone in the
woods no there wasn't a TV screen there
wasn't advertising there wasn't I got to
get back and watch you know Westworld
no none of that was going on in their
lives so if you ever had a chance of
making such a discovery about the
natural world it's not good I don't
think it's gonna happen while you are
distracting yourself with modern media
or they hang out on Facebook or anything
else on the Internet it's just not
unless something there gives you an idea
you could be a fertile person you know
it's an idea that's an idea but then you
step away and develop the idea how about
that okay so for me that's what's behind
that and one of my great disappointments
in the corona verse the corona verse
quarantine is I'm not giving myself
enough solo time because I'm catching up
on email and I'm doing and I you know
I'm cooking and I'm perfecting some
recipes both my wife and I we both like
food so that we're doing that there's
some other things was not call light let
me just be alone and think and write so
I'm failing on that myself but and plus
not everyone is Isaac Newton you know so
yeah that's an understatement
[Laughter]
yeah oh by the way Isaac Newton all
evidence suggests that he was I don't
call it quite a misanthrope but he did
not really enjoy the company of other
people he never married he never had
kids so if you don't enjoy the company
of other people then being sent to the
country home in Lincolnshire away from
other people that's a godsend to you
right yeah and so yeah there you have it
yeah I forget I don't know I forget who
said this but gosh she's there's a
writer and she said the greatest
impediment to creativity is distraction
oh yeah sure definitely yeah bye and
basically write a lot of what you just
said and another there's another saying
which is if you want to be more creative
then become less productive right yeah
that see now that's where I'm a Viking
well yeah because what when you say oh I
went shopping I did this I'm ever and
look how much that God did get done
today well did you create anything
chances are the answer is no yeah well
you don't you don't give your mind a
chance to do that say yeah yeah cool
alright so here we go this is Alfredo
Baldo cassiano who says short off now in
the mood yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
says dear friends I have a black hole
question if a black hole is a point of
infinite infinite density that means it
can bend the space-time so much that a
particle falling inside can accelerate
so much that it can reach the speed of
light now he put a question mark at the
end he wrote it as a statement but he's
asking it as a question so if a particle
falls into a black hole it is the
gravity so strong
since light can't escape will it cause
the particles coming in to reach the
speed of light going in
they'll come close depending on how far
away they they emanate but but no no no
the answer is no so so you can calculate
it so the escape velocity is greater
than the speed of light
it means if they just put it right at
the speed of light just for this example
if you went the speed of light you can
escape the black hole it'll keep tugging
on you slowing you down but you'll reach
infinity and have zero speed there it's
weird to speak on these terms if you had
more than the escape velocity you'll
reach infinity and still be going okay
if you have less than the escape
velocity it just pulls you back so it
depends on what distance you fall into
the black hole from and and you'll and
you can calculate what your speed is and
it's not in most cases it's not anywhere
near the speed of light for that it's
not two so the answer is basically nope
no yeah all right come on a lot of
material spirals into the black hole
really this it doesn't just yeah because
as you see these disks of matter are
that the 'true cooler
we should disk very good very good I got
a chrétien disc of my own right here
that's what the you and your wife for
cooking see that's the results good
accretion discs cooking there's another
cookbook right maximizing the accretion
disk so yes so in fact most Mammoth
Falls is black hole is spiraling and
it's not just falling straight in very
cool this is
[Music]
FLV lq i don't know what that I don't
know what that is
from Instagram he says it looks like a
random pips on a keyboard
it really does and lvo cute he says
while I was listening to the podcast I
heard about nuclei getting spaghettified
if the nuclei get spaghettified aha here
we go
what about the Clarks I have an answer
for that I don't know yeah I have two if
I read guess I would say it also
spaghettify as the quarks Wow
because it's pretty bad down there it
really is and tastes nasty it is I mean
you are literally tearing an atom apart
whoa wait so so you tear the atom apart
by ripping off the electrons that's
nothing that's right right well then
yeah go ahead
electrons are easy yes but then the
nucleus which is very tightly packed
that gets spaghettified and they're
asking now that you spaghettified the
nucleus now you have the nuclear
particles right protons neutrons and
they that are polarizing quarks right
hence I think the answer is yes but we
got it well pulling Janna on our next
episode to see what she says
but my mic I think my answer is yes
nothing nothing survives a black hole
Wow damn that's really just disturbing
you know you know be fun that's a good
poem that needs to be written ready
everything flowing in to a black hole
gets spaghettified except spaghetti I
already know one thing should have oh
that's how that's all I'm saying that's
a lot of power okay this is what else
you get Teague Griffin Teague weeping
people are making up stuff now man Chuck
this have to be the last question could
spend too much time with jury a ting on
these answers yeah it's okay and we've
got Equis pen from Instagram says this
what are your thoughts on the simulation
theory how likely is it that it exists
now yeah so okay I'm happy to end on
that because my thinking on that changed
in recent weeks and Chuck did we do it
yes we think that's wise that go ahead
and do it so yeah yeah yeah so all right
so I now think where there's a better
chance that were not in a simulation
than I had previously imagined okay good
now let's stop there and now go find
that explainer so we can get more views
on YouTube and I'm gonna say and Michael
Bruce wants to know this how can we yeah
that's right now go find it go find that
it's later on YouTube and we're gonna
get our eyes we're gonna get more views
now so Michael Bruce wants to know this
how can a while you're there subscribe
yeah make sure you subscribe so Michael
Bruce wants to know this how could we
prevent a mass extinction event when the
world governments believe more in
listening to who pays them / scientific
fact so a better question I mean not a
better question a different question is
how we elevate science to a place of
respect when it comes to our leaders in
government you know I wish I didn't have
to say this but maybe science needs
better advertising you know you know
politicians can get you to like them
just by a series of ads maybe we need
that for science this there's science in
your life that you don't even know is in
your life that's keeping you alive and
breathing most people who are alive
today are alive because of some
scientific advance in food production
and prenatal care and of the health and
sanitation just I don't think people
it's easy to take something that's so
embedded within your life for granted so
once you do that then people will then
see and understand what science is how
it works and then they'll respect it and
and then we won't go extinct from
short-sighted politicians I hate to say
that because science shouldn't need
advertising right but maybe we teach
people you know maybe if you teach them
to constantly see and embrace it then
you don't need the ads teach them that
in school and so every day hey that's
science hey that's science hey what if
you do that then you it's built in to
the system
so by the way when we were going to the
moon every day you were reminded what
science was because we were going to the
moon you didn't need room you didn't
need someone say oh we need more science
teachers how do we attract them they
people would climb it over themselves to
study science it's a technology and
engineering and math because they saw
the fruits of that in that era so yeah I
don't have a good answer the extinction
may be in our future for that very
reason I'm science and I approve this
message
on that happy note we gotta call it
quits there are electic galactic bold as
that gumbo our potpourri this has been
star talk cosmic queries Chuck but as
always thanks for being my co top
scorers Neil deGrasse Tyson here bidding
you to keep looking up
[Music]